welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka your insider on
the outside air and this video are
breaking down episode 7 of the show last
week ended on a big cliffhanger in this
episode definitely feels like one of the
most tense yet we're gonna be going over
the entire entry as a whole and giving
our thoughts on it there will be heavy
spoilers here so if you don't want
anything potentially ruin it then I
highly recommend that you turn off now
without the way thank you as always for
clicking the video now let's get into
our breakdown of the outsider episode 7
okay so episode 7 centers around Holly
and where we left her last week the
episode does an excellent job of making
us think that she's on the highway to
hell and while she comes out of it okay
by the end the 50 minute long ride
really has he fearing for her safety at
points D'Andrea itself has a feeling of
people being doomed to their fate and
this is exemplified in the opening shots
when we see a cockroach sprawled on its
back this signifies a lot throughout the
episode and it can be applied to several
characters when a cockroach has had its
nervous system compromised because of
insecticide the creature will often flip
onto its back and have spasms it's
pretty much a death sentence for the
roach as it's very unlikely that it will
ever return to its upright position it
is possible that it will but oftentimes
the cockroach is stuck like this until
it dies instantly this can be applied to
Jack who is now 100% connected to the
outsider and should Holly survive she
will bring this to people's attention
jack has gone fully off the deep end and
is unlikely to come back to his normal
upright position and at points similar
to the cockroach he himself ends up in
the woods scrambling on his back from
the roach we cut to Ralph and his bed on
his back and then he sits upright
Ralph's belief in the rational has
impeded the case and left him
unaccepting of the truth behind it many
police officers before him have to been
solid in his mindset and the cell cuoco
has been able to continue its killing
spree for centuries similar to the
cockroach they have been stuck in a
position unable to move but what's
interesting about this shot with Ralph
on his back is that he sits up this
shows that he may have broken free of
being stuck and is now willing to
progress on the
case with an open mind though he's still
not fully on board there are hints
throughout the episode that he's slowly
starting to come around keeping an open
mind pretty much became a catchphrase in
the source material and personally I
believe that's what's represented here
it's a beautiful introduction and I
can't believe I've spent over a minute
talking about something that happens
over about the space of three seconds
this hub of Ralph's coming around is
quickly squandered though when he tears
down sketches of the creature I believe
that these may be put up in the future
to signify his acceptance of the
supernatural and this episode is very
much about him beginning to believe Jack
does tell a joke about how many shrinks
it takes to change a light bulb
and he says that it's only one and that
it's the light bulb that really has to
want to change this highlights that
Ralph can do it but he has to want to
it's not long before he realizes that
Holly has been kidnapped and Ralph could
also have other big problems on his
hands we learned that glory could be
contemplating soon the police department
and though she initially states that she
doesn't really want to this mindset
changes throughout the episode we also
see that they finally found a nanny that
wasn't a reporter and she's returning to
work so she has turned to an upright
position
however she quickly flips back over and
becomes stuck when shiba rights clients
and we realized that three weeks was
probably too soon to return to work she
gave us a strange pitch to them and it's
a bold one I'll admit but you son of a
[ __ ] I mean it really seems like she
wants to be as far away from the case as
possible and not see the police
department but after being said to be
broke she changes her mind and decides
to go ahead with it we then finally
could to Holly and Jack and the tension
is at fever pitch jack spews dialogue
about how he didn't really believe in
anything growing up but now he does
since encountering the outsider he
doesn't even seem like he's hiding
anything and instead this car ride early
on even sounds like a therapy session he
spouts about how the creature is endless
and could date back to before the Big
Bang and how there may even be others
Holly did say last week that the
creature wasn't of this world and
because of this we guessed it could be
from another dimension or from space
similar to penny wise both penny wise
now cuckoo feed on emotion and
shape-shift and it is possible that they
are both millions of years old we do
know from Kings work that there are also
others out there like it Jack feels like
he's the dominant one here and this is
why he doesn't mind confessing to Holli
it seems like he wants to work with her
but every time he does the rash flies up
he asks why al cuoco chose him and is
said that it focuses on people who are
dealing with loss and pain as mentioned
earlier it feeds on emotion and where
Pennywise fed on PA her kooka feeds on
grief and despair jack as we know lost
his mother recently and his wife left
him and this is why he was in a
vulnerable position that enabled him to
be chosen
we've theorized that claude will be the
next target and this is given wait here
when we see him losing his job because
of the fight of the strip club last week
he's clearly a man down on his luck and
we already know that al cuoco is
transforming into him due to the fact
that when it was Terry and cut him al
cuoco operates by cutting someone and
then from this it takes their DNA and is
able to mimic their appearance
we know the monster is currently going
through a transformation and as Claude
has just been let go it provides the
outsider with the perfect victim the
manager does say later in the episode
that he quit but it doesn't really come
across like that I could imagine that
ship could be found as the suspect of a
crime that many would hold this job loss
against him is something that could have
pushed him over the edge later in the
episode Holly confirms that Claude is
the next victim there is a ticking clock
against him that I'll talk about at the
end of the video Ralph and Polly
discover Jack's room and see that as
blood everywhere because of the fight
that he had with his mother instantly
they assume that he's kidnapped and
killed Holly and they managed to track
the two using their phones Colin says
that she's transferring from the
department due to life being easier out
of the way of the murders
Polly does the old I need the toilet
trick and the tried and tested method of
getting out of something nearly works
but Jack asks more questions and then
she uses the next-in-line excuse of
having a period God knows saying I'm on
my period has gotten me out of some
tight situations am I right girls she
even tries to climb out of the bathroom
window and clearly Jack hasn't seen well
anything other than a strip club dance
before she manages to get away and Ralph
and Pelle have
similar conversation to Holly and Jack
about the supernatural pally discusses
his childhood in which he encountered
something strange in the woods but Ralph
shrugs it off showcasing he refuses to
believe in the woods Jack puts a gun in
his mouth but kampala trigger and the
ends on his back sprawling around much
like the cockroach at the start
Holly makes it back to Ralph's and she
discusses what's been going on this
confirmation that the outsider only
feeds on children and that Jack may have
wanted to take her to a kill box there
is some way given to the theory that he
may have been grappling with everything
as the gas station was in the opposite
direction to the barn but we just don't
know for definite Jack is a slave to Al
cuoco similar to how Tracy Powell was
and we see that Ralph's refusal to
believe anything is what's holding the
case back Ralph is pretty much standing
in the way of everything and it's time
he either gets with the program or gets
out of the way he goes to his therapist
and tries to find someone who was on his
side about it and Holly has a nightmare
at the end that she was murdered by Jack
which could indicate that Al cuoco is in
ahead and haunting her it is possible
that Jack could now be hunting her as we
did see that he was alive and making his
way back to town Ralph needs to get into
the investigation ASAP otherwise she
could become someone that'll cuoco
tormance next and whatever happens
something needs to change from next
week's episode we can see that jack is
now out and about killing people with
his rifle this indicates how far he has
come and what he is willing to do is a
police manhunt out for him so he'll have
to do whatever he can to avoid the long
arm of the law the investigation seems
to be making headway as they brought
Claude in for questioning and asking if
he feels like something is fixated on
him Ralph isn't there but as we know
he's slowly starting to open up and this
could also be cemented by his first
encounter without cuoco which appears to
be in his home there's also a masked
festival in which a child goes missing
at the person who looks to be escorting
the boy away appears to be caught on the
surface though his base is hidden behind
a mask but body-wise they look very
similar this could show that the
outsider didn't have time to fully
change its appearance but as it was
about 90% there it's decided that it's
close enough Claude looks like he's
being locked up and the fight for his
freedom will likely be what concludes
the season there's lots of things going
on and overall this was another gripping
episode and with just three left I can't
wait to see what happens now obviously
I'd love to hear your thoughts on
episode 7 and what you thought of this
season so far
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoy this video then please drop a
thumbs up and make sure you check out
our entire breakdown of the season so
far we've got a big playlist of a ton of
videos on the show so it's definitely
worth checking out if you want to know
more you want to support the channel
from is that this 99 cents a month then
please click the join button below you
get access to content early and can also
suggest video topics and breakdowns you
want to come chat to us after the show
either follow us at definition whitey
I'll click the discord link in the
description below every month we give
away free movies to people or subscribe
to the channel and this month you can
win the nfinity saga box set and all you
have to do is comment on a video and
make sure you soak with notifications on
the winners gonna be chosen at random on
the 15th of march it's the best of luck
that everyone who takes part this is the
channel for people who are never missing
television so if that's the kind of
thing you like you need to subscribe to
definition thanks again for taking the
time to watch this you've been the best
and I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
[Music]
you